dunque quando la statistica del 99 per
cento diventò il nome del mobile
street nell'ottobre del 2011 le analisi
economica
che stavano già da alcuni anni
denunciando l'aumento della
disuguaglianza come abbiamo visto anche
da queste slits tra il 2002 e il 2007
l'un per cento della popolazione
americana aveva visto crescere la
propria ricchezza del 61,8 per cento
mentre per il 99 era aumentata solo del
6.8 per cento e poi negli anni della
crisi tra il 2009 e il 2012 recupero per
l'uno per cento era stato del 31.4 per
cento mentre per il 99 per cento solo
dello 0.4 per cento a fronte di questa
forbice è straordinaria misurata e
denunciate da piquè t7 steve blake la
risposta ufficiale della federal reserve
bank di san lewis fu categorica come il
titolo del suo rapporto della primavera
del 2010
il mio quality income or in comune
quality and stop so bad la
disuguaglianza di reddito non è poi così
cattiva così negativa l'introduzione del
progetto del movimento del 99 per cento
di occupy wall street
elenca però alcune insopportabili
diseguaglianze che la diseguaglianza di
reddito comporta nelle società di
mercato
cito noi siamo il 99 per cento cacciati
dalle nostre case costretti a scegliere
tra mangiare o avere una casa senza una
sanità decente costretti a vivere in
aree insalubri degradate a lavorare per
molte ore con poca paga è ormai nessun
diritto oppure stare senza lavoro
noi non prendiamo nulla mentre l'uno per
cento prende tutto
ora io vorrei dedicare questo mio breve
intervento non approvare che la
disuguaglianza ingiusta ma a mostrare
come la diseguaglianza sia stata e sia
giustificata come giusta
il rapporto della federal non è
dopotutto un'eccezione
una premessa e in realistico affermare
che eguaglianza e disuguaglianza siano
assoluti sono concetti relativi la
massima di marx a ciascuno secondo i
propri bisogni significa appunto che noi
non siamo uguali siamo diversi
e però uguali come parte della specie in
relazione ad alcuni bisogni di vita
fondamento
ancora il diritto politico uguale il
suffragio universale per intenderci ci
fa tutti noi cittadini uguali nel potere
di prendere decisioni di giudicarle come
voler dire che poiché siamo diversi e
presumibilmente anche diseguali molte
cose
la democrazia stabilisce però che tutti
siamo uguali nel potere politico
primario quindi uguaglianza politica è
stabilita in modo da far sì che noi
siamo uguali in qualcosa di importante
proprio perché le nostre diseguaglianze
non devono diventare ragione di sopruso
di potere di subordinazione quindi
l'eguaglianza per legge condizione di
libertà tenuto conto che siamo diversi e
questa idea di uguaglianza che viene
periodicamente messa in questione non è
un caso che proprio partire dal tempo in
cui l'eguaglianza politica ben affermata
cioè lante l'atene classica vennero
teorizzate le ragioni della
diseguaglianza per cui abbiamo il poeta
solone che parlava di uguaglianza e il
filosofo platone che teorizzava la
disuguaglianza come allora in altri
momenti storici le teorie della
diseguaglianza si sono fatti i muscoli
per contrastare le rivendicazioni
dell'uguaglianza politica nell'antichità
furono i dialoghi platonici a fare
questo lavoro negli anni a ridosso della
rivoluzione francese furono i teorici
del pensiero tradizionalista o
reazionario da ed un barca donoso cortés
de maistre e solo per citarne alcuni
nella seconda metà dell'ottocento gli
anni della lotta per il suffragio furono
i testi di nice
solo per citare il più noto a tessere
l'inno della diseguaglianza in tempi a
noi vicini vicinissimi con la democrazia
costituzionale che nessuno sembra in
teoria contestare la retorica della
disuguaglianza viene usata dalle
dottrine economiche dell'indirizzo
liberista contro le politiche delle
uguali opportunità e la tassazione
progressiva
cominciamo dall antichità che ha imposto
impostato la matrice di tutte le teorie
delle disuguaglianze tra gli individui
platone e fa dire a calli che nel gorgia
che l'eguaglianza e la vendetta della
legge degli uomini contro
peggio della natura cito e sì perché in
natura tutto quel che è più brutto è a
un tempo più malvagio ossia il subire
ingiustizia per la legge invece è
commettere ingiustizie il brutto la
legge degli uomini rovescia la legge
naturale e ordina di non sopraffare
l'altro punisce nonché sopraffatto e
perde come natura ma chi prevale
aggiunge callicle offrendoci un monito
che mai dovremmo dimenticare che
l'uguaglianza per persistere nel tempo
ha bisogno di essere inculcata
generazione dopo generazione perché
diversamente la disuguaglianza tornerà
ad essere ammirata più dell'uguaglianza
e a vincere sul campo della lotta per il
potere accalappiati fin da piccoli
scrive nice nella genealogia della
morale
i migliori vengono plasmati secondi
valori che hanno inventato i perdenti
per sopravvivere senza sforzo
cito impasto iandoli a incatenando lì
come si fa con i leoni per domarli li
osserviamo dicendo loro che bisogna
essere uguale agli altri e che in tale
uguaglianza consiste il bello il giusto
l'uguaglianza dunque la legge dei deboli
che sono più numerosi escogitata per
renderli forti per artificio numerico la
sua casa e naturalmente la democrazia al
governo dei peggiori perché i deboli
sono la maggioranza e non coraggiosi i
vendicativi con coloro i pochi che sono
forti potenti la democrazia usa la conta
dei voti per vincere la gara del potere
e la tassazione progressiva per
atterrare i pochi l'uguaglianza può
operare in due modi come elevamento di
chi sta in basso e come atterramento di
chi sta in alto dall antichità e in
maniera ricorrente la democrazia è stata
spesso identificata da chi la vuole
sminuire con la seconda atterramento
verso il basso come il sistema che
spinge giù chi sta in alto che frena la
superiorità per invidia
oggi si parla di merito più che di
superiorità e la ragione è che in una
società che come la nostra comunque
abbracciato l'eguaglianza politica
la disuguaglianza deve essere meritata
ovvero riconosciuta da tutti non può
essere imposta se non altro calli
clinici non avevano remore a sostenere
apertamente che i migliori non hanno
alcun merito se non l'essere
naturalmente superiori non devono
attendere alcun riconoscimento sociale
nessuno deve dirgli se lo meritano
il superiore è tale perché capace di
vivere senza riconoscimento degli
inferiori il suo è il coraggio dell'eroe
ecco perché la democrazia per le linee
qualità ri è il peggiore governo perché
si legge ancora nel gorgia i più deboli
credo bene che si accontentano
dell'uguaglianza sono vili e non
vogliono rischiare la lotta vogliono il
paracadute della legge uguale per tutti
e sappiamo che la lotta del demos contro
gli aristocratici fu prima di tutto la
decisione dei poveri di dirsi uguali in
potere ai ricchi e dovette prendere il
potere un poeta per convincere con belle
parole che i disprezzati molti erano
uguali dei bisogni ai divinizzati pochi
fatti della stessa pasta
come diceva solo né pensare che
uguaglianza e individualità possono
stare insieme è stata per i grandi
attori del passato almeno fino alla
seconda metà dell'ottocento un
incongruenza radicale perché la
distinzione l'eccellenza la preminenza
individuale sono i caratteri che
l'ordine secondo la legge degli uomini
cancella e umilia le uguaglianze dice
che non c'è superiore inferiore ma solo
diversità di espressione di una comune
natura umana i suoi critici dicono che
in questo modo i caratteri visibili e
peculiari dei singoli individui lasciano
il posto ad un'astrazione reputata
comune a tutti l'umanità dalla quale
sono fatti derivare i giudizi sul bene
sul male sul giusto e l'ingiusto ma chi
ha mai visto un essere umano
chi ha mai visto l'umanità e vi si
chiedeva sarcastico che diceva di vedere
solo inglesi tedeschi italiani francesi
ma non uomini e basta non umanità
l'umanità e basta la comune
umana che è una costruzione sociale
scriveva amareggiato dice ha consentito
di esaltare tutti i caratteri che sono
contro natura i deboli i mediocri i
vigliacchi ed è stata elevata falsa come
a norma universale del diritto e della
morale l'uguaglianza che la legge degli
uomini impone esprime pertanto
un'attitudine negativa e ha una funzione
repressiva non aggiunge toglie eguali in
difetto reprime prima nasconde il valore
e così l'utilitarismo egualitario del
jeremy bentham era considerato da
nietzsche auto repressive calvinista
cioè una logica democratica tramutati in
etica è una filosofia dell'ordine
ugualitario secondo la legge che
cancella l'ordine della natura nella
società moderna di mercato a raccogliere
il testimone della giustificazione della
diseguaglianza e l'individualismo
economico il pensiero che noi chiamiamo
in italia liberista o neoliberista che
si appella ai diritti umani naturali per
esempio e soprattutto quelli della
libertà di scelta e di proprieta ben
teorizzati da john locke nel seicento
per i liberisti contemporanei
l'uguaglianza è nelle regole della
competizione nelle opportunità offerte
dal mercato e nei diritti fondamentali
di libertà che riconoscono a ciascuno di
noi la padronanza sulle proprie energie
fisiche e mentali come sulle cose che
possiede e scambia ma attenti bene
uguali nei diritti di possedere
scegliere finiamo fatalmente per essere
disuguali nei risultati
la regola uguale serve a giustificare
l'esito diseguale il quale sarà più
facilmente accettato da tutti si è visto
come il frutto di una lotta combattuta
direttamente da noi
secondo regole uguali la competizione
come la conquista del west
la società come la prateria
potenzialmente tutti possono partecipare
alla corsa e farcela
il fatto è che appena la corsa comincia
alcuni sono già avvantaggiati e il loro
vantaggio
non si sa nulla
ma si accumula e rende quella che era
all'origine una posizione di partenza
uguale già una condizione di privilegio
anche se non più visto questo privilegio
in questo modo perché all'inizio della
corsa che si guarda sempre è quello
serve a giustificare la diseguaglianza
così che con il passare del tempo quelle
regole uguali non si applicano più a
tutti ugualmente ma da alcune meglio
peggio che ad altri e ciò non
scandalizza più nessuno
questo è dunque largo vento più
convincente questo del nostro tempo
perché è condiviso anche dagli
svantaggiati esso convinci perdenti che
la disuguaglianza se la meritano perché
frutto del loro minor impegno delle
poche conoscenze insomma delle loro
libere scelte per individualismo
economico quando e se la competizione è
lasciata libera gli esiti non possono
che essere diseguali e questa
diseguaglianza e giusta
inoltre poiché il rischio di perdere
tutto resta sempre possibile queste
disuguaglianze dovrebbero tendere col
tempo bilanciarsi fino creare armonia
sociale e giustizia che è distribuzione
dei meriti cioè di quel che si ottiene
via mercato distribuzione giusta perché
non imposta per legge per esempio quelle
politiche redistributive ma sorta
spontaneamente dalla gara economica di
qui la massima di robert nozick da
ciascuno secondo quel che sceglie a
ciascuno secondo quel che ha scelto
in altre parole noi siamo responsabili
di quel che abbiamo scelto chiedere
l'intervento pubblico è giustificato
solo se sostieni perdenti con la carità
e la filantropia ma senza violare le
regole del gioco economico senza
adottare politiche di giustizia
redistributiva o di uguali opportunità
proprio perché chi perde perde a causa
delle scelte che ha fatto merita quel
che non ha siamo così ritornati alle
posizioni di calitri nel borgia quando
la legge civile interviene per
correggere la diseguaglianza viola la
giustizia naturale e rovescia lo stato
delle cose
quel che è giusto cioè il successo la
riuscita viene calmierato come se fosse
ingiusto e quel che naturalmente
perdente viene sostenuto
per vie artificiali per concludere la
teoria della diseguaglianza può essere
condensata così non a ciascuno secondo i
bisogni ma ciascuno secondo il rango
distribuzione di potere politico tra chi
è uguale in alcune cose ritenute
superiori come la ricchezza la
competenza la conoscenza il coraggio in
guerra o nella gara economica la
politica deve seguire la natura dunque
la quale non conosce uguali ma vincitori
e vinti nella gara della vita
ieri gara militare oggi gara economica
oggi assistiamo questa rinascita in
grande e della politica delle
disuguaglianze nelle piccole e grandi
scelte anche in quelle locali
quando per esempio si vuole legare il
destino degli studenti alla famiglia al
territorio nei quali per caso sono ben
si sono venuti a trovare e che sono
spesso luoghi di grande diseguaglianza
di potere economico e culturale ma
rispetto della persona e delle sue
potenzialità ha bisogno delle uguale
condizioni di partenza senza le quali il
merito è un trucco
grazie
[Applauso]